a month ago i ran a poll asking people
what they thought of game of thrones
season six
my theory was that the reception of
season six especially after the end of
the show was pretty mixed
and we can see from the poll results
that it's a little split despite there
being a majority for good for the aim of
the video i wanted to analyze the season
as a whole and determine where i think
it would fall on the spectrum and why
the season is so
mixed so first let's look at the
disparity in the quality of writing
within season six
and what i mean by this is that from
scene to scene or even in the same scene
the quality of writing drastically
changes
we can have genuinely good moments that
are immediately followed by horrible
moments
the best way to illustrate this point is
by obviously showing examples
i won't pull from the most popular
moments from the season so instead we'll
look at some normal scenes throughout
some of the episodes
so the first example i have happens
within the same scene
where theon supports yard's claim to the
salt throne
i think this was a pretty good moment
because it acts as a fulfilling
character arc for theon's redemption
and how he betrayed yara in season 3.
it's overall very wholesome
and gives us some long-awaited payoff
between these two characters
but then the scene is ruined when it's
followed by a horrendous appearance by
euron greyjoy
he basically comes in blurring a bunch
of annoying nonsense
funnily enough he admits to even killing
balon greyjoy and for some reason
nobody cares not a single person was
loyal to him
then when theon raises this good
argument you weren't here
past i heard you were gallivanting
around the world having a grand old time
euron replies with a [ __ ] joke that's
the sort of thing you start to say once
your dick gets chopped off
and after that it just evolves into your
unspouting more [ __ ] jokes
even heard you have no [ __ ]
and give it to daenerys targaryen along
with my big [ __ ]
wow this is hilarious david and dan you
really know how to introduce and create
a compelling villain
magnificent job it's just jarring how
the scene's quality subsided so quickly
and how the writing took an immediate
nose dive
for another example i'll pull two back
to back scenes that differ greatly in
quality
the first one is cersei and jaime
grieving over the loss of myrcella
the opening of the scene is outstanding
with a slow push on cersei as she slowly
starts to realize that her daughter is
dead
it's a great shot showing cersei's
evolution that then leads into her and
jaime's grief
also this scene isn't just them grieving
because that would fundamentally be
boring but it also re-establishes cersei
and jaime's compelling relationship
that and cersei spills the beans on her
believing the prophecy about our
children which warrants a cool reaction
from jaime
it's a shame that we didn't get a scene
like this when tommen died cersei's last
son
but that's a little off topic this scene
is then followed by varys and tyrion
having a stroll through meereen
and why is this scene so bad he may ask
because the dialogue that david and dan
write for these two characters is
atrocious
because you have no [ __ ]
these are the two smartest characters in
the show and their dialogue devolves
into childish jokes
are you kidding me then david and dan
make a joke where tyrion seems as though
he's trying to eat a baby
this entire scene adds practically
nothing to the beginning episode
and the only revelation is that the sons
of the harpy are still terrorizing
moraine which could have been disclosed
in some random dialogue scene
but from these examples i start to see
multiple trends for season six
since dave and dan are running out of
source material they were apparently
only supplied and outlined for the winds
of winter
now as to how developed the outline is
is a mystery
so the only explanation for the
disparity in writing i can think of
would be david and dan cherry picking
good lines of dialogue and moments from
the outline
and then adding in their own material
because this inconsistency
is so jarring to the point of where i
don't know whether to like or dislike
some of the episodes
we can have tyrion in one scene again
making a [ __ ] joke
and then he immediately turns around and
gives us a witty line
it just seems as though david and dan
are playing fill in the blank and each
blank they fill in is garbage
like an example of a massive filler type
scene is the play in braavos that arya
watches
this feels like some weird deleted scene
that should have been cut out but
ironically david and dan double down and
decide to give us two play scenes
to give some context for this scene arya
is supposed to be observing this girl
her target
since she's proving herself to be a
faceless assassin but she ends up
watching the entirety of the play
multiple times like why are we spending
so much time here david and dan
oh yeah comedy oh
no also on an unrelated note it's
driving me crazy that a random play in
braavos
includes tyrion and its recap of events
but the song of ice and fire book being
written at the end of season 8
doesn't include tyrion now that's pretty
wild
but to conclude this point for season 6
every episode is filled with both
terrible and good moments to the point
of where the inconsistency of quality
hurts each episode it's easy to forget
about some of the bad scenes and moments
after not watching the season for a
while and only remembering the best
but there is quite a bit of garbage you
have to wade through to get to the good
moments of the season
a part of why season 6 comes across as
being outstanding or good is that every
subplot has some form of big payoff
this inherently increases the enjoyment
factor of the season because we are
getting epic resolutions to plot lines
that have been building for several
seasons
this is in large part a thank you to
season 5 because that season did a lot
of build up for season 6
and because of that season 5 was
mediocre because of all that build
up some examples include boring plot
lines like ramsay torturing sansa which
fuels the battle of the bastards
daenerys dealing with the sons of the
harpy which builds to their defeat in
season six
and another one being cersei having a
feud with the sparrows
which has paid off with the great sept
explosion if you were to take away the
payoff of season 6
it would become more mediocre like
season 5 but with more bad scenes
however that's not the case so let's
look at some of the payoff for season 6
and see if it's actually good
the main example that annoys me the most
that can definitely be improved
is arya's payoff of becoming a faceless
assassin
this gets thrown into motion when the
wife is sent after arya for not killing
the actress
for this initial moment where the wave
stabs arya i listed it as being the
ninth stupidest moment in the show for
my top 25 most stupid moments in game of
thrones video
this whole sequence is packed to the
brim with abundant plot armor
plot conveniences and an underwhelming
end to the bravo's faceless assassin's
story line
also this is a plotline in which the
build-up was mainly arya sitting around
doing nothing like washing bodies and
doing chores
so we waited through two seasons to
watch arya kill the waif off screen
tell off jaqen who never comes back and
then she kills walder frey which was a
good scene but that was the last time
she uses her powers
this overall payoff for arya is
underwhelming
it also sucks because conceptually this
is one of the coolest subplots which in
essence is about assassins wearing the
masks of other people
and it is somehow one of the least
interesting subplots of the season
this is primarily because david and dan
barely do anything with this concept and
the climax is just a generic chase
through a city
the only interesting thing that was done
in season 6 with arya was her using her
powers to kill walder frey
but again that most likely came from
george rr martin's road map
and even its execution was very rushed
given that arya was in braavos at the
end of episode
8 and somehow made it to the twins by
episode 10.
so before looking at another example of
payoff i know there are some really good
instances like the battle of the
bastards and the great sept explosion
but i wanted to analyze those two
sequences as a separate point at the end
of the video because they are what is
regarded as two very memorable moments
in game of thrones by going back to the
payoff of other plot lines
we have daenerys defeating the sons of
the harpy and yet again
this is another very underwhelming
ending for a plot line that has been
built up to
for three seasons the ending just
consists of dany coming back with her
dragons and destroying one
ship and the enemy giving up that's
really it it lasted about 5 minutes
it was overall a very lousy fight if you
can even call it a fight and it made all
the build up seem like a waste of time
because of this the sons of the harpy
plotline is even more unbearable to
watch since it's really not worth it in
the end
the three master villains are completely
underdeveloped and barely have any
screen time
so it makes daenerys victory seem even
less satisfactory
to compare this with the high sparrow he
has a lot more build up and through many
different scenes
we learned how manipulative he can be
which thus makes him a more menacing
villain
not just some two-dimensional slave
traders and daenerys has already freed
the slaves so that leaves the masters as
the only remaining obstacle in our plot
line
and as an obstacle to overcome they were
just really boring
it's very apparent that this resolution
is completely overshadowed by the battle
of the bastards
given that they're in the same episode
it just feels like a betrayal to
daenerys plotline to handle her
three-season arc victory
in just about five minutes i know she's
technically really powerful and she can
end the fight quickly
but having the enemy give up immediately
is just boring
have the masters be more arrogant and
stubborn and stopping their attack
so that daenerys can have an even bigger
slam dunk on them
this would at least create a more
satisfactory outcome because we would
see daenerys full strength at play
but in the scene's current state it just
felt like daenerys was going easy on
them
unfortunately in terms of all the other
payoff in the season
it was pretty good they revealed that
jon snow was a targaryen through the
tower of joy
sansa getting her revenge sam starting
his path of becoming a macer
are all very enjoyable however the two
other big portions of payoff with ahri
and daenerys
are so underwhelming that it leads to
the season being more mixed
so taking a break from talking about
some of the payoff and plot lines
i want to look at an aspect that isn't
discussed a lot which is
the cinematography for season 6
i think it looks the most beautiful out
of the whole show whenever i think of
game of thrones
this season stands out the most in terms
of visuals this could be attributed to
the season getting a higher budget which
was
an increase to 10 million per episode
when it used to be six to eight million
this does allow for sequences in the
show that would otherwise not be
possible to achieve with the smaller
budgets
the main one being the battle of the
bastards and how epic the cinematography
was in that episode
this singular shot of jon snow facing
off the horde of the enemy
is stunning the zoomed in nature of the
shot giving the illusion of the horses
being closer than they actually are
the great perspective and juxtaposition
of jon versing the whole army
and the overall shot composition is
perfect
and this is just one frame from an
episode that is packed full with awe
inspiring visuals
even this long take tracking shot of jon
snow fighting his way through the
battlefield
is something we've never really seen
before especially for a tv show
this outstanding cinematography
significantly boosts the quality of the
episode
given that it's so visually appealing
even though the battle the bastards is
flawed which i'll get into later
it's overwhelmingly uplifted by
magnificent visuals
it's kind of like the concept of a
polished turd but battle of the bastards
is by no means a turd so it's like a
good scene that's polished to become
even better and more memorable and this
is just an example of the cinematography
in regards to the main action set piece
of the season but the actual
cinematography during normal dramatic
scenes
is still breathtaking most of the time
even during this scene where sir jorah
is saying goodbye to daenerys
the cinematography still knocks it out
of the park
the smooth creamy shallow focus of these
medium shots for daenerys and sir jorah
creates an aura of warm intimacy between
them
for me this elevates the emotional punch
of the scene and it gets
even better when the scene progresses
further and we transition to close-ups
to capture the more detailed emotions
any shot here looks like a painting and
the color palette is so
satisfying and this basically applies to
almost any dialogue
seen in the season another example being
kinvara talking to varys
this utilizes the same techniques i
highlighted previously
but i think the blocking and shot
composition in this scene
has a subtle and powerful impact
throughout the scene
varys was criticizing the red priests
and when kevara brings up varys past
the power dynamic shifts to kanvara this
is emphasized visually when she steps
closer to the frame
and it seems as though she overpowers
varys despite her being physically lower
on the staircase
this is a very chilling scene that is
boosted by the cinematography
and obviously the great acting to give
one more supporting point as to why i
think season 6 has the best
cinematography
i want to compare two different scenes
from separate seasons that are in the
same location
for this example we'll be looking at two
scenes from winterfell that take place
in season 5
and 6. right away you can see that the
lighting is a lot better in season 6
or it's more thought out in terms of
where the actors would be in relation to
the lighting
for season 5 some characters like bruce
bolton are not even lit properly and the
main light source is hitting his hands
in comparison to season 6 where each
character generally has a bright light
on them creating a nice contrast
or the light is behind the character and
it creates a highlight around their
portraits
these shots are definitely better than
the ones in season 5
and i personally like the color
correction more in season 6
given that the saturation seems a bit
higher but overall
since the cinematography is so great in
season 6 i think it elevates the appeal
of the season as a whole
despite some scenes or moments being
genuinely bad
so for the final point of the video i
wanted to analyze the two most memorable
sequences from the season
and those are the battle of the bastards
and the great sept explosion
so first let's look at the battle of the
bastards
so as i said earlier in the video this
is undoubtedly a great action set piece
that is
uplifted by gorgeous cinematography
however
i think there is one essential flaw that
hurts the sequence
which is how devoid of logic it is
first of all johnstone was beefed the
hell up
with plot armor the fact that he
survived running into ramsay's trap
survived eight archer barrages a cavalry
charge
swarmed by enemies and even smothered by
his own allies
is crazy at the very least he should
have gotten some injuries from the
battle but he comes out unscathed
you're right i was luckier than most i
find it funny that
one run-in with egret is more deadly
than running face first
into thousands of soldiers
now the reason why this use of plot
armor is so heartbreaking
is that it goes against the very nature
of what game of thrones used to be
a show that had consequences for
characters making mistakes
for battle the bastards jon snow should
have died given that he played into
ramsay's track
imagine if rob stark miraculously got
saved during the ride wedding
it would just feel cheap instead david
and dan structured the episode to
include a deus ex machina in which sansa
saves the day with the veil
and this also raises another point that
doesn't make sense in that
sansa intentionally withheld the
information that she had the support of
the veil for practically no reason
i would have told you not to attack
winterfell until we had a larger force
or is that
obvious when will we have a larger force
we've played it with every house that'll
have us she was just going to let john
die
potentially because she didn't trust him
or something like what
i think this whole scenario is one of
the most stupid events in the show and
it feels as though david and dan wanted
to limit jon snow's side to make it seem
as though he was the underdog
in actuality if the show made sense in
the moments
jon snow should have rolled through
ramsay's army if he had access to the
veil from the beginning instead of them
coming in later
so in general the battle of the bastard
sacrifices logic for
epic spectacle however they could still
have epic spectacle
if david and dan did a better job with
the writing
so going on to the next sequence we have
the great
sept explosion there is a lot about the
sequence that is great
but i think it misses a core aspect of
storytelling and that is again
a lack of consequence as a
self-contained sequence
it's pretty good but you have to look at
the larger picture given that this is a
long running
series as an example a part of why the
red wedding was so memorable was
obviously the heartbreaking twist and
the impact it had on the world after the
event took place
everyone the episode after was talking
about the red wedding
but who was really talking about the
great sept explosion after it happened
do all the citizens of king's landing
just not care anymore
what happened to the importance of this
line that was set up in the same season
every one of us is poor and powerless
and yet together we can overthrow an
empire the only scene we got as a result
of the great sept explosion was a few
brief mentions from different characters
and jaime being mad at cersei but that
wore off pretty quickly
so imagine if the red wedding had the
same treatment in terms of the story
afterwards instead of the north
remembers it would basically be
the north forgets there would be no
lasting impact and would feel as though
it wouldn't matter that much besides
just ending a plot line
so as it stands the great sept explosion
acts as a means to only move cersei to
the queen position of the seven kingdoms
and to delete a bunch of characters that
will no longer be relevant to the story
this is the main negative aspect about
this sequence but there is obviously a
lot of great aspects about it
i think by far the best aspect is the
music
ramen ninjawater really carries the
scene and it wouldn't be the same
without the trial the seven track
it also helps that david and dan barely
include any dialogue in this sequence
given that that's normally their worst
contribution
but since there is barely any dialogue
this allows the cinematography and score
to carry the sequence into the s-tier
status
also the pacing of this whole sequence
perfectly complements the music and
creates some outstanding
synergy that slow ramp into the climax
as the characters realize what's about
to happen gives you chills every time
overall it's an awesome sequence that is
unfortunately brought down by bad fall
up later on in the show
if game of thrones ended after season 6
then the great stepped explosion would
practically be perfect
but as it stands i think it's pretty
good and not utter perfection
as some people may say so with these two
great sequences that are somewhat flawed
the appealing cinematography payoff that
is hit or miss
and the disparity in quality of writing
puts the season in a more
mixed reception because of this i think
season 6 belongs around the area of good
and ok there are qualities that elevate
this above the season being trash
however there are aspects that bring the
season down from it being outstanding
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video and
if you liked it i made other video
essays on season 1
4 and 5. and for the next one i'll be
looking at season 7 and where it goes
wrong
have a good day and let me know what you
think about season 6 in the comments